this from slate.com
curious trend has taken hold of the
automotive community until recently your
only options with vehicle ownership were
to purchase the car outright or to lease
it from a dealership but in a growing
number of metropolitan areas a third
option is emerging car subscriptions
evolve all is the latest to start using
a subscription model at the Los Angeles
Auto Show this week the company
announced that its upcoming XC 40
compact SUV which started $600 a month
subscription with a two-year contract
just like how you might buy a smartphone
yeah
the verge explains in its post about
this news which raises the question
isn't this just the same as leasing a
car in some ways yes but not exactly
when you lease a car you pay a monthly
sum to rent the vehicle until your lease
expires can be a logical option when you
don't have the cash necessary for a
hefty car down payment no it can't be
that would be stupid
a lease can allow you to drive a car you
might not be able to afford which is
kind of a hint you the driver still have
to handle getting your own auto
insurance and maintaining the vehicle
it's typically under warranty during the
whole lease period Ford Porsche Cadillac
and neva ball are among the car makers
giving drivers the option of a
subscription the biggest difference is
the time frame rather than being tied to
a year's long lease subscriptions give
the ability to COO well on the car you
don't own that you're renting it on a
month-to-month basis you could theory
like theoretically not have a car for 10
months of the year when you're working
and using public transit and then get a
car subscription for two months when
you'll be traveling more often these
subscription plans include insurance
saving the time and headache of hunting
for a policy yourself also unlike a
lease you may not have the option to buy
your car at the end of your term car
subscriptions appear to be a clear bid
to garner favor with the tech savvy
Millennials in busy metropolitan areas
rather translation tech savvy
Millennials in busy metropolitan areas
translate
suckers suckers okay just get that out
of the way most Millennials as it turns
out don't always want to rely on uber
and public transportation for their
needs still a subscription model less
commitment than to purchase more
convenient than a car rental service
like Zipcar would fit the bill for
drivers teetering on the edge of
abandoning car ownership well when you
lease a car or rent a car or subscribe a
car you have abandoned car ownership
stupid people okay or ones who can't
quite afford the car of their dreams
which would be people that did stupid
stuff like get a subscription to a car
looking at costs over the long run it's
likely the car makers who will win out
in the end
no really you think they're doing this
to make money no way if the idea of car
subscriptions catches on as fast as
other mobile subscriptions have it's
basically an all-inclusive lease but
with less commitment seems downright
logical if you can get a subscription
for everything from music to meals why
not your daily driver - okay let's kind
of work through critical thinking skills
people okay the car company covers the
maintenance the car company covers the
insurance the car company covers the
loss and value while you are renting
this car for two or ten months and they
bundle all that together and they charge
you more than the total of that per
month because they have to make money I
mean they don't stay open if they don't
make money they're not a nonprofit
organization they're not doing this for
the goodness of their heart they're
trying to make a profit and they're
trying to make even more profit so when
we do get the numbers on this and none
of us got to actually have the numbers
on this yet when you actually get the
numbers on this you're gonna find this
to be the most expensive possible thing
because here's the thing okay do I rent
cars yeah when I'm in another city I
rented an SUV the other day for the day
or two days okay because I don't really
need to buy a car when I'm in LA that
would be kind of silly for two days
right
so I rent the car how
if you were to extrapolate the rental
rate with Hertz
or the rental rate with whoever
enterprise those the two primary ones we
use and you were to say let's rent the
car does Hertz make more money on the
day if you multiply the daily rate times
365 right and you kept the car for a
year those Hertz make more money on that
then you know then the car dealer does
leasing you a car yes a lot more I mean
you kind of stupid if you don't already
know that right
that the daily rate of a rental car
multiplied times a year or if the days
would be vastly more expensive than
owning a car vastly more expensive even
than fleecing a car and vastly more
expensive even than this stupid new
subscription model so that's kind of one
end of the spectrum is you know you
could just rent your car when you need
to just not I don't use a car so I'm not
I'm just gonna rent a car okay
but the bottom line is you're paying for
it when you rent a car by the day the
good news is when I ran that SUV for two
days I think I ended up with I don't
remember what it was there's like 80
bucks or 90 bucks or whatever it was it
may be maybe 110 I don't remember
something like that
110 dollars does not change my life but
if I did that for months on end and I
had a typical household income that
would change my life financially because
it would be so freakin stupid
mathematically I mean you know that
right
that's why you don't go rent your cars
from Hertz I'll never buy another car
again I'm just going to rent my car and
anytime I want to turn it in and today
I'm going to drive a truck and tomorrow
I'm going to drive a Lamborghini and
tomorrow I'm gonna drive it Prius and I
can just have the selection and key stay
updated on all the technology and it's
easy for me I don't have to think about
anything I don't have to go to the
trouble to get insurance I don't have to
go to the trouble to put tires on it I
just don't have any problems at all but
I'm so stupid and broke it's
unbelievable because mathematically I'm
getting taken to the cleaners you know
that right you would never use that kind
of a logic line to handle your vehicular
needs your transportation needs
and just go I'm gonna go rent a car from
Hertz by the day you'd have ultimate
selection you'd stay up on technology
you would have no trouble with insurance
you'd have no trouble with maintenance
of any kind and if anything happened you
just call Hertz and say come get your
car but you would be paying such a
premium for that the everybody would
look at you including you looking at you
in the mirror and go there's a stupid
person right you'd know that or leasing
is just a dial down version of that and
subscription is going to end up between
the two it's not gonna be as dumb as
renting your car by the day it's not
gonna be but it's gonna be dumber than
renting your car call the lease the
bottom line is vehicles go down in value
60 to 70 percent they lose 64 a new car
loses 60 to 70% of its value in the
first 4 years you own it so a $30,000
car is worth 11,000 after 4 years that's
the average according to national Auto
Dealers Association and kept lungers I
mean when you just get to get the
numbers out on the car and look at it
the car you're driving look it up look
up the brand new one what it costs and
look up what a 4-year old one is and
tell me that's not a 60 to 70 percent
loss almost every time it is it might be
a 50% loss on some of them and it might
be an 80% loss on others but they go
down in value
like a rock that's where Chevy got that
like a rock when they drop it and value
like crazy and if you don't think that
loss and value is gonna be encompassed
in your payment's you're a stupid person
of course its encompassed in your
payment's and if you have regular car
payments on debt it's not encompassed in
your payments but you end up upside down
on the car you owe more on the car than
it's worth because your payment's didn't
even cover the depreciation you're not
even paying enough down on your debt to
keep up with how fast it's dropping in
value
I can guarantee you Hertz is covering
that I can guarantee you Enterprise is
covering that and they're not evil for
doing so the service they provide is a
short term usage and so this idea that
you should subscribe to your car is
freaking absurd because tech-savvy
Millennials that's stupid
don't blame ticks tech-savvy Millennials
are smarter than that
tech-savvy Millennials are savvy Sammis
one of the words there you would never
do this crap if you were savvy in any
way and if you need a car for a month
rent you a car
okay rent you a car that's fine but if
you need a car longer on the month you
need to go buy cheap car and pick cash
for it hello hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show